[Música]
resultado histórico en colombia la
coalición de izquierdas capitaneada por
gustavo petro lidera las votaciones
legislativas en donde se votó para
elegir al total de curules para la
cámara de representantes y el senado
en esta votación se esclarecieron
también los candidatos de las tres
principales coaliciones para las
presidenciales que tendrán lugar el
próximo mes de mayo gustavo petro
federico gutiérrez y sergio fajardo
fueron los ganadores de esta jornada
el ejército ruso continúa el asedio y
expande su ofensiva en el oeste de
ucrania este domingo bombardeo con
misiles una base militar a sólo 25 km de
la frontera con polonia dejando al menos
35 fallecidos y más de 130 heridos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos victoria histórica de la
izquierda en colombia que celebró
elecciones legislativas en donde la
coalición de izquierdas pacto histórico
fue la más votada tanto el senado como
la cámara de representantes en estas
elecciones se votaba también para elegir
los candidatos presidenciales de las
tres principales coaliciones electorales
aquí también en parte histórico es el
principal vencedor desde que gustavo
petro recolectó más de 4 millones de
votos los otros ganadores fueron sergio
fajardo para la coalición centro
esperanza y el ex alcalde de medellín
federico gutiérrez en la coalición de
derecha equipo por colombia en el
siguiente informe veremos quién es
federico gutiérrez
es la sorpresa de la derecha colombiana
federico gutiérrez zuloaga más conocido
como fico nació en medellín la segunda
ciudad más importante del país y desde
sus primeras incursiones en la política
el ingeniero civil de profesión se
posicionó con el conservadurismo a sus
28 años consiguió ocupar el puesto de
concejal de su ciudad con el partido
conservador unión por la gente tras un
primer intento fallido en 2011 fico se
hizo con la alcaldía de medellín a
finales de 2015 puesto que ocupó hasta
el 2019 con la misma línea política
desde entonces su propuesta actual es
sigue siendo en un país en orden y con
oportunidades con un programa a favor
del sector empresarial para crear empleo
y con la promesa de mano dura contra la
violencia y delincuencia en el país
similar a la de iván duque invertir
necesitamos a usted un país y un estado
austero pro vicente pero aquí hay que
entender cuáles son los dos modelos es
un modelo de quienes quieren destruir
empresas y otro que es el nuestro donde
queremos cuidar la empresa y que haya
más empleo otro modelo que lo que quiere
es expropiar y nosotros lo que queremos
es que por el contrario el campesino
tenga el título de su tierra la pueda
explotar a pesar de ser ex alcalde de
medellín chicos se presenta a sí mismo
como una cara nueva para la presidencia
de colombia y goza de un gran apoyo a
nivel nacional aunque también ha estado
envuelto en controversias durante su
periodo como alcalde se acusó a varias
personas de su gabinete de corrupción
además se filtró que fico usó dinero
público para financiar una campaña de
desprestigio con bots en redes sociales
contra políticos opuestos a su plan de
gobierno en un entramado conocido como
la bodega de fico a continuación a la
santana nos cuenta quién es sergio
fajardo candidato del centro esperanza
conocido como el profe en colombia por
su fuerte campaña a favor de la
educación en el país sergio fajardo
creció en la ciudad de medellín el
doctor en matemáticas empezó a ser
reconocido como docente en la
universidad de los andes mientras
escribía columnas de opinión sobre
política y educación en varios medios
colombianos fue en
1999 cuando dio el salto a la política y
se convirtió en uno de los fundadores
del movimiento compromiso ciudadano que
llevó 22 años y medio haciendo
repartiendo los volantes mirando a la
gente escuchando la medida de lo posible
lo que le piensan las personas de manera
libre y exportan en la calle más tarde
en 2003 fajardo se convirtió en alcalde
de medellín el político de centro ocupó
el cargo de gobernador de antioquia
entre 2012 y 2015 todo tras su intento
fallido de optar a la presidencia en
2010 seguido de otra candidatura
fracasada en el 2018 se ha mostrado con
violentos y corruptos poniendo las
pautas y ahora viene el momento de la
inteligencia de la capacidad del talento
en su proyecto político
fajardo defiende una reforma tributaria
en la que y más los que más tienen y
apuesta por acabar con la desigualdad
mediante la educación con la promesa de
que ésta llegaría a todas las zonas
rurales vamos a derrotar el continuismo
la corrupción y el desgobierno como
otros políticos del país a fajardo
también ha sido acusado de
irregularidades durante su periodo como
gobernador no obstante está siendo
investigado por un supuesto fallo en la
supervisión de un proyecto y no por
corrupción
vamos ahora a ucrania que sigue ocupando
una amplia parte de la actualidad
internacional allí las autoridades del
país informaron que las tropas rusas
habrían asesinado en irvine al
periodista estadounidense brent reno que
se había desempeñado como colaborador
del diario the new york times al tiempo
otros reporteros resultó herido en un
tiroteo el fotógrafo
colombo-estadounidense juan arredondo
resultó herido en este mismo ataque
en fin estábamos cruzando el primer
puente en irvine y vamos a grabar a otro
refugiado yéndose y vamos a [__] un
coche que alguien os ofreció para
llevarnos al otro puente cruzamos el
puesto de control y empezaron a
dispararnos así que el conductor dio la
vuelta y continuaron disparando nos a mi
amigo vendré no le dispararon en el
cuello y lo dejaron atrás
desde que estalló la guerra josé jesús
pacheco ha estado en la primera línea de
la ayuda humanitaria en su parroquia
este venezolano que desde hace nueve
años vive en ucrania ha ayudado a
contrarreloj a dar refugio a unos 1500
desplazados por el conflicto bélico
a pesar de la guerra el venezolano jose
jesús pacheco decidió no huir y ayudar a
salvar vidas lo encontramos en la
parroquia juan pablo segundo en libia
última escala de decenas de desplazados
antes de escapar a otros países tuve la
oportunidad de haber estado el año
pasado en venezuela en un país que para
mí no era el que yo conocía hace 10 años
cuando salí de venezuela y dio mucha
situación mucho sufrimiento el
sufrimiento del inocente y creo que todo
eso me preparo para para poder afrontar
esto porque mentalmente y físicamente es
muy agotador 12 horas escuchar porque mi
labor más que todo en el día es ayudar a
las personas ir a hablar con ellas un
poco no de intentar en medio de esta
oscuridad que que ven que puedan recibir
esta buena noticia de que dios nos ha
olvidado de ellos de que dios está
presenta ese sufrimiento y esto es lo
que yo intento intentó llevarle con mi
presencia acá en la parroquia refugio
apenas hay hombres jóvenes la mayoría
son mujeres y niños
[Música]
en toda una familia todos son hermanitos
confieso que no pienso que como
latinoamericanos que somos más
sentimentales a mí se me hace más
difícil afrontar cada situación digamos
que este es muchas veces los
sentimientos juegan en contra porque no
como cuando estás conmovido y quiere
darle un mensaje de consuelo a una
persona y con tantos sentimientos que
lleva es difícil en estas habitaciones
hay decenas de niños mujeres que han
encontrado aquí refugio hay ropa que
están donando las asociaciones
humanitarias que están ayudando a estas
personas en esta parroquia que solía
tener sólo tres personas como habitantes
ahora hay unas 200
aquí le preguntamos qué piensas qué
piensas de todo esto y muchos dicen que
lo único que puedo pensar ahorita es en
que vuelva la paz
cuando aún no es mediodía josé jesús se
despide de este grupo de desplazados que
van a ser evacuados en autobús su
destino en roma' el de josé jesús
asegura el seguir aquí con los más
vulnerables
y terminamos en irán donde la guardia
revolucionaria dice haber atacado un
centro estratégico israelí en el norte
de irak según el gobierno regional del
kurdistán iraquí tenían como objetivo
los intereses estadounidenses en la
ciudad
2 dios mío qué es esto este es el
momento en que uno de los misiles
balísticos lanzados desde irán impacta
en erbil la capital de la región
autónoma del kurdistán iraquí los
proyectiles parecen haber caído en su
mayoría en terreno abierto causando
algunos heridos y daños materiales en el
canal de televisión kurdistán 24 y en
algunos edificios residenciales escena
no
sentimos el impacto de los misiles
cayeron muy cerca de nosotros con los
cristales rompiéndose sobre nosotros
usamos una manta para cubrirnos
intentamos salir de la habitación pero
el suelo estaba cubierto de cristales
rotos
salimos de la casa y vimos tres fuegos
ardiendo sobre el pueblo de mulá omar
pensamos que los misiles habían
alcanzado el consulado estadounidense y
la guardia revolucionaria iraní
reivindicó la autoría de los ataques al
asegurar que habían apuntado a un centro
estratégico israelí sin embargo las
autoridades kurdas insistieron en que
israel no tiene ningún emplazamiento
cerca de él y afirmaron que el objetivo
era el nuevo consulado de los estados
unidos aún en construcción
del departamento de estado de los eeuu
calificó el ataque de atroz afirmó que
ningún ciudadano estadounidense resultó
herido y que no hubo daño en sus
instalaciones
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
con nosotros
[Música]